cbs news poll just out this morning
finds that president biden is getting a
positive reaction to his state of the
union speech last night 67 of the people
who saw last night's address say that it
made them feel optimistic now we need to
mention that the people watching were
most likely to be from the president's
own party that is usually the case with
presidential speeches joining us now are
cbs news chief political analyst and
senior national correspondent that's
john dickerson and cbs news chief
foreign affairs correspondent and face
the nation moderator that's margaret
brennan
lovely and blue this morning welcome to
you both john is is that a true
indicator when you're polling most
people who are already part of the who
represent the party don't you expect the
numbers to be high well yes you expect
the numbers to be high although in the
current weakened political state for joe
biden he's having some weakness in his
own party so it's a good starting place
to be doing okay in your own party uh
but these numbers you want to get you
want to be at 67 rather than seconds
but the news cycle is not joe biden's
friend to the extent that he was trying
to position himself somewhere because
already people are going to hear new
news from ukraine
the pace of events is going to kind of
move on to the next thing how much of an
impact then do you think that speech
will have historically they don't have
that much of an impact but they lay out
a road map and so what will be most
interesting really is what joe biden
talks about on the road in wisconsin and
other states which of the many many many
many things that he talked about
will he make priorities because that's
what really matters and then of course
the other thing that's most important is
that he did stand there as a defender of
the western view that that
self-determination and freedom are
american ideas that need to be protected
and that is something that traditionally
americans have rallied around the
president when the president stands for
those ideas which are knit so thoroughly
into the american value system margaret
he started as he needed to with the
situation in ukraine he mentioned uh
president putin several times and says
that he has no idea what's coming
how do you interpret that what's the
strategy there well the president there
trying to message strength and not
through military might in fact the exact
opposite saying we will not use our
military in ukraine that's something
that resonates both with both parties
right now uh there has been this uh
opposition to use of military force in
terms of sending in combat troops for at
least three presidents now but his
emphasis on diplomacy for those who
didn't pay attention to the ruble
plummeting more than 30 or the fact that
you know brent crude is trading over a
hundred dollars a barrel they did hear
oh we're seizing yachts oh we're seizing
private planes so when the president put
in those concrete terms of what the
department of justice is going after for
the oligarchs the cronies those who have
made themselves rich off of vladimir
putin's regime that was something to put
in very concrete terms for people and i
think on the russia story
people do understand the framing of a
bully a well-known one vladimir putin
going into a democracy and seizing it
and so
that is something that in principle has
had support among both parties but
certainly in the public sphere democrats
believe this is a winning issue for the
president to look strong that he has
united the west even though a lot of the
unification came from fear among
european countries he does seem to be
getting bipartisan support though when
it comes to his handling of ukraine
right so far so good
tactically there was some difference
about whether he had should have put in
stronger sanctions earlier really
sort of punched putin in the gut before
he moved in rather than reacting to the
intervention but democratic leadership
would argue he had to do that to keep
the west united that is all politics is
local the 27 countries within the
european union weren't ready to take
some of the actions that we have since
seen them take because there would be
blowback for their own economy in this
country though john most people are
worried about inflation his message last
night seemed to be lower your costs not
your wages to companies do you think
that resonates well it's a it's a strong
economic argument if you keep making it
yeah i mean so the problem with
inflation is that it's a negative ad for
the person in power every time somebody
goes to the checkout counter so you need
as a politician to give them an argument
for why either they should hold on
because it's going away or you've got
some solution and in a political year
where the president we nationalize our
politics so what the president says
affects all these democrats running in
these various races so did he give them
an argument those democrats running in
those races it's going to last all the
way through november for how his
economic policies affected the number
one economic thing people care about
he's got the material there but the
question is does he keep talking about
it because his policies for inflation is
one set of ideas then there was this
unity agenda whole different set of
stuff so which is he going to choose
politics is about choosing and
repetition so now we'll see it might
work but it only works if he doesn't
shut up about it well you know 21 states
in this country raised their minimum
wage as of january the president made
that argument that it should be up to 15
an hour like federal workers get
you can argue that but when your dollar
doesn't go as far because of inflation
it kind of offsets the issue you can't
just tell companies lower your costs
they're also paying inflated costs yeah
he was talking about that
unity agenda we saw senator manchin
sitting with republicans we asked
the vice president about she said well
there's no assigned seating anyone can
sit anywhere but did that strike you as
odd that he was sitting with republicans
senator manchin argued that it was to
demonstrate the need for bipartisanship
but you're hitting on something that
that john gestured to there which is
differences within the president's own
party when you have a unified democratic
leadership it has not looked very
unified when it came to democratic
senators specifically joe manchin all
right margaret brennan and john
dickerson we are up late yesterday this
morning together i like it thank you
very much following your lead yeah thank
you very much